cause probably doesn't that one of your
because you acted in in school but you
were in school
I mean how posh is this you got to see a
school production and Tom Hiddleston's
in it with Eddie Redmayne okay well um
yes uh he was a great talent even then
he was at the start he was a huge star
and we were in a school production of A
Passage to India by p.m. Forrester
there must be some really depressed
barons but you can see that passage -
they're doing a Passage to India I have
no idea yeah so all-boys school they're
only halfway Eddie was a great Eddie
Redmayne the now oscar-winning Lee and
Redman was playing the female lead and
in in the passage to India there's a
there's a expedition to this cultural
landmark called the Mara bar caves by
elephant I'm delighted to reveal that I
played the front right leg of the
elephant the Peggy Eames for of you to
make the elephant that's right yeah yeah
I was sitting on you he's he's sitting
we're holding a table and with a cushion
on top of it and also table cloth to
cover our faces because with our bodies
of the elephant yes oh that sounds awful
just got that picture in your head okay
imagine sitting there thinking I haven't
had a drink we're at school they're
carrying at some boy dressed as a girl
on a top four table my son's favorite
front leg
I got a good say that's my boy right I
am being rude that you have a beard of
any revenue you haven't appeared no I've
never there was a point at which I was
almost gonna be Carson something with
him but apparently our faces next to
each other we would both have
extraordinary looking faces so they
thought they were too weird-looking next
to each other on screen that's what I
was told by the producer they said that
our faces are took both from a to
extraordinary to be opposite each other
on a on one frame Wow I've got a picture
of Eddie let's go to picture video yeah
so you call right yeah - no apparently -
extraordinary looking weird faces and
look a bit related I think I've been
actually it my little sister that would
put it that would look bigger loss
suppose we lovers rather than brothers
and sisters we waiting for the subplot
the whole way to the phone
[Music]